Newsweek says secret tunnel under New
York synagogue Sparks katak scenes but I
will not bury the lead I will simply
just play for you this video so you can
all say holy what the is going
on for those that are listening the
video depicts a Jewish man climbing out
of a secret tunnel in the sidewalks of
New York City swatting at the camera and
then running away it looks like a Skip
and uh again my favorite tweet from this
is uh imagine seeing a Jewish man climb
out of an underground tunnel in New York
sidewalk not having your camera to film
it and trying to explain to your friends
what you saw without sounding like an
anti-semite it's already been a wild
year man this is insane so the story is
there's a Secret Tunnel built under a
New York synagogue the police show up
cement trucks come to fill in the tunnel
soiled mattresses are pulled from this
crevice young men then rip the walls
down of this wood paneling and break
through the wall to try and occupy the
space to to stop the the uh construction
Crews from cementing it in when the
police show up young Jewish men fight
the police and a dozen are arrested and
now everyone is saying what the is going
on with secret Jewish tunnels in New
York
City the Jews are hanging out with the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles um so I
have a friend that that would be the
cool explanation that would be the fun
one um I have a friend that is a uh
young Jewish man that lives in lives on
Long Island and he sent me
some information about this apparently
there is a sect of young Jewish men that
are considered uh they're Israelis from
a secr a fringe sect of Judaism to come
to the US as teenagers to study with
little to no supervision they have no
money awful living conditions in no
regard for anyone or anything outside of
their ridiculous beliefs that
essentially amount to treating the L
Luba vicher rebe who passed away in the
90s as a deity they consider him to be
the Messiah and refuse to acknowledge
that he is no longer alive the rumor is
that they dug the tunnel so they'd have
unrestricted access to the main
synagogue here when it's closed as it
was for a bit during covid um the
apparently the re used to give dollars
out every Sunday along with other
blessings people would line up so he was
an icon and there there are there's a
sect of Judaism that thinks he is the
Messiah and I apparently they had a
underground tunnel to cuz they were
fighting the man so do you think that's
what this is look when I when I saw the
police coming in and then these young
men start fighting cops
I'm like zealotry immed ideological Ze
zealotry there's no there's there's 0%
chance you save this tunnel once they've
discovered it the idea that a dozen
young Jewish men could fight the police
off and preserve this was insane the
only reason they would then do it is if
their ideology was stronger than their
logic in their minds they're thinking I
know we'll lose but for this reason we
must fight to protect our secret tunnel
uh yeah I I think it's hilarious I I've
got the wikip the guy that they're
talking about that has passed away his
name is Menachem Mendel schne schneerson
I swear to God I'm not making this up
I'm going to copy the Wikipedia on the
guy I got it right here yeah so menm
mendal schneerson yeah so he he's he's
he's dead yeah but they believe he was
what a deity or something this this
particular sect apparently believes that
he was he is the Messiah and uh
uh he was he was well- loved by by
people in the community and and I guess
in according to Jews and stuff but uh
there there are people leader of the
Shabad lubovich movement how do how do
the tunnels come into play here though
that's they didn't want to be held down
by the man they wanted to be able to get
the synagogue man oh this was because of
lockdown that's what people say that's
what people say but it's it's years
later now right there they're still not
locked down so why would people still I
got to be honest if if young men built
tunnels so they they could go and and
worship their First Amendment right when
the oppressive dictatorship of the state
was trying to suppress their
constitutional right that's based yeah I
mean 100% don't fight cops but what yeah
but what are like what are they still
doing down there if it's I guess if you
have a cool tunnel like you still use
the cool tunnel but it's I I don't know
if that's the explanation they are men
there's got to be something else yeah
but there there's a there's a very
interesting uh question to be had in
this case what we saw in New York with
the shutting down of churches and
synagogues was unconstitutional judges
had ruled it
unconstitutional and Cuomo said go ahead
I'll just make another executive order
and shut these things down the people
who were committing the crimes were the
police officers trying to stop people
from expressing their first amendment
rights the Constitutions the law of the
land in which case these young men who
built a tunnel to be able to go into the
synagogue to worship when they were
being oppressed by the dictatorship by
the communist authorities were they were
in the
right yes clearly I mean the lockdowns
were the the most clearly
unconstitutional especially when in the
context of people that wanted to go and
practice their religion I personally am
not a Believer but it's protected in the
in the Constitution clearly there's no
there's
no ambiguity about you you know you have
the right to assemble and you have the
right to practice your religion there's
you know I mean the or this the country
can't make the state can't make a uh
laws regarding religion so clearly they
they had no authority to do that and
there's been there's been no you know
nothing's happened since nobody lost
their jobs no one got fired you know and
and and let's let's let's segue this
story about secret Jewish tunnels in the
most likely and appropriate Direction MH
Civil War so when uh we are now dealing
with a question of at what point let me
let me let me put this way this show is
always about being on the correct side
of law don't break the law you handle
things appropriately if the cops come to
stop you you comply and then you fight
in court because fighting a cop on the
street doesn't do anything for you there
are limits however and people ask this
question at what point must you defy a
police officer well obviously if the
police officer is committing a crime you
are not obeying the law by obeying a
police officer who committing a crime
right like if a cop went and was robbing
a bank and then ordered you under threat
of law to help fill his duffel bags
you should not do that I mean well I'm
not going to tell you what to do because
if he's threatening your life yeah but
if he says if you don't do this I'll
arrest you I'd be like bro you're the
one committing the crime I'm not going
to do this here in lies the Big
Challenge we are dangerously close to
this point nay we are already in it
where we are seeing police officers
engage in illegal activity we are seeing
border patrol officers engage in illegal
activity and this this issue of the
tunnel under the synagogue brings up a
really important question sooner or
later it will be impossible to answer
what is the right side of the law so
again what we say is you see a video of
a guy and he's being stopped by the
police and he fights the cops and the
cops defend themselves and the guy dies
and then everyone's like oh the cop's
racist and I'm like dude if a cop is
stopping you don't fist fight him you
keep your mouth shut you put your hands
behind your back then you get in touch
with your lawyer and you win in the
system which we have built to to to deal
with these things but what happens when
the police are shutting down churches
illegally and now the police are
basically kidnapping and threatening you
with violence without actual Authority
the problem there is the New York City
Government asserts the authority to do
it the Constitution says otherwise and
the judges have said otherwise how would
we Advocate would we tell you no these
cops are committing crimes you should
ignore them then YouTube says Nope the
cops are always right what's what's the
stance that the broadcasters will take
you literally honestly in a real if
you're going to actually talk about this
as a realistic situation the cop's got a
gun you do what the cop says the long
and short of it the guy with the gun is
the one that you listen to get out of
that situation because you're not going
to win a gunfight and the and the
government's not going to say okay this
is good no no no no hold on hold on a
guy shows up wearing a badge that says
the new Republic of New York and he's
got a gun and he's wearing a uniform and
he says you now are under my
jurisdiction we assert Authority here do
you listen to him uh you you are at that
point is there is someone trying to
force you to do something that is
illegal you you have been kidnapped by
that guy and you get away from them you
escape if possible my Appo my my my
point here is that you're making the
assumption that the person wearing the
badge of New York City is operating
under any kind of constitutional
Authority no I'm making I me by saying
you should Escape I'm making the
assumption that they're illegitimate the
point here is this this is a point that
I've made numerous times as it pertains
to these stories what happens if someone
knocks on your door and you go and
there's a clown in total clown Garb
standing there and and you're like who
are you what do you want and he says I
am the clown Bureau and we are here to
arrest you we have a warrant would you
actually listen to the clown buau I mean
look the ATF shows up at everybody's
house every now and again right the
point is you clearly recognize a man in
a clown costume is no legal Authority
that's absurd what happens when a person
shows up claiming to be law enforcement
but the view and the confidence in the
system is thus that you look at it like
a clown costume like the easier way to
explain it is a guy shows up wearing a
bad you're in California and he has a
new California Republic badge sheriff
and you're like there's no such thing as
the new California Republic so you're
essentially asking what happens when the
government loses legitimacy with the
average person when the authorities do
what happens when it's split and no one
knows fair enough so right now it's very
simple to say if the police show up you
just you you you adhere to the system
you get a lawyer you fight it the best
way possible which is in the courts but
what if the police start killing people
what if what if a police officer what if
what if uh uh I mean look let's let's
just entertain what this tunnel that
they built allegedly was so that they
could keep going to church to synagogue
when they were illegally barred from
doing so we saw in New York the police
were barricading Parks locking them up
and shutting down schools they were
spying on schools there was one video
where a guy's restaurant was closed he
had his door open because he was
cleaning and a health inspector came in
and gave him a fine for being open he
goes I'm not open I'm closed and they
were like your door is open and he was
like What if someone claims they have
the authority of government and are
violating the law we cannot Advocate
that you adhere to a man who's breaking
the law that would be telling you to
actually be party to law Breakers but we
have seen police break the law under
color of law we are we are at this point
right now since covid and the questions
all the question more seriously is on
the southern border federal law
enforcement are assisting illegal
immigration they're committing crimes
yeah this is why I got to say this is
why it's so important elections matter
elections have consequences right we
have to have people in an executive role
or in government that are representing
us that's supposed to be representing us
that are looking out for our and this
this covid example Rings true in my own
Community where I was a mayor and I said
no I said no to mask mandates no to
vaccine mandates as one of the very few
I had our County uh County authorities
call me and say you need to be enforcing
social distancing at your parks and your
cops your city cops they need to be
enforcing mask mandates and handing out
fines and I said go pound sand I mean
this is this is not and and that's what
we need to do we need to find people
that have exhibited that type of courage
and that backbone and and support them
in officewise we get what we have today
I think that I whereas I do think that
the point you're making is is correct I
think that it
is far worse of a situation in that it's
not about finding people that are
running that's that have these policies
or that are talking about these policies
it's that con it's convincing the people
that are voting that these are the
correct policies I think that the the
the there are people that say Hey I
would do this I would do that that that
that are at least pointing in the right
direction and I feel like the average
person has been again talking what we
were talking about earlier what I was
mentioning earlier how the average
person has been so so indoctrinated by
the the by comedy centrals you know a
call on politics that they don't have
any understanding of why the policies
that they're hoping for won't work at
all they don't have any understanding of
history and and I think that that's the
majority of our problem is the people
that have the people that that are now
in HR departments and in and work in
government and stuff like that and and
and
leading uh in polit polit in political
positions in in cities Across America
they've all been taught that liberalism
is not actually the system that we
should be supporting and so I think we
need people we need we need a society
that values these things and unless we
have that we can guarantee that they're
going to vote for frivolous ridiculous
things that don't work yeah I I want to
ask you uh a question about this because
one thing that we're constantly saying
on the show and one thing I think
basically everyone in this sphere is
saying non-stop is that we need people
to actually stand up for their values
it's great to have the right ideas it's
fantastic to know what's going on but
ultimately when push comes to show you
have to be willing to stand up for them
so I'm curious what inspired you to
actually take a stand and say we're not
doing this mask mandate stuff and when
did you reach this conclusion cuz I
could just say personally when this all
first started happening I want to say
for the first like couple weeks I was a
little nervous right and I thought maybe
this is something and I will wear a mask
but I want to say by the time we got to
April or May um I I was really not with
it anymore and then I I just remember
when the media was completely okay with
BLM rioting and when doctors literally
signed a note saying that that was
acceptable I went oh it was just
nonsense um but yeah I'm curious like at
what point did you come to this
conclusion and what um inspired you to
stick to your guns there because a lot
of people weren't a lot of elected
leaders were not no no and sadly that's
true um but I think just inherently I
knew that this was wrong and uh right
away in about March of 2020 uh I went on
and said quite uh vociferously that I
was opposed to any mask mandates
whatsoever then news came back around uh
in May I believe it was of 2020 where I
said yet again look I am not going to be
utilizing my Police Department to
enforce these things I think it's
heavy-handed this is not constitutional
and maintain that stance for you know
for the entire time so I it is I I think
you're absolutely right Phil that we
have unfortunately it's not just certain
media channels but it's the it's the
educational system that we have in this
country where we have dumbed it down so
bad and more than that we're actually
teaching people the wrong things we have
so few people that are I think
economically and civically literate Y
and that's it's just unfortunate um or
just literate we were talk no I mean it
we were talking about this ear and I'm
not just talking about low reading
scores what I'm saying is with
widespread literacy it seems as if we
became satisfied teaching people to be
able to sound out letters and then know
what the word was without actually being
able to truly comprehend the deeper
message of what's being said this this
this is a a typical argument against
Mass literacy programs that I've heard
from uh I'm not against Mass literacy
programs I just think like they're not
real literacy programs we're teaching
people like how to sound words out we're
not actually teaching them how to really
truly read there was this great article
I read a long time ago one of the things
that played a factor in me not going to
college that argued that college is
great for the people who've decided
college is the path for them in that you
uh grow up building computers and you
want to go somewhere where you can learn
to build computers better you have the
capability to build computers and you
want to learn from the best what we did
then is we said everyone should go to
college no matter what the problem there
is this article said something like you
need an average IQ of about 110 to
actually go to Higher Learning that
means you can read and and not just
memorize but actually comprehend the
idea that is uh uh that is shown to you
and the problem now is by telling
everyone to go to college people of 100
IQ will easily memorize the literature
but not actually understand what it
means what ends up happening then is
after a few years they'll have this
jumbled up confused concept which they
think will make them smart they think
they're smarter than everybody they
actually have no idea what they're
talking
about that I think is a good example of
what's happening in this country you see
a lot of that also you know people will
will throw this stat around and they'll
mention like oh yeah to to graduate from
college like on average your IQ is going
to be around 110 115 but I think that's
outdated uh I I'm almost certain that's
not the case anymore I think I think the
a colle probably an IQ of like 105 maybe
maybe 100 even well the average IQ is
100 that's the point no no that's what
I'm saying I don't think the average
college grad is that far above average
anymore agree I don't think they're 110
115 yeah I think the issue is often
brought up we have a lot of midwit in
the political space these are people who
are slightly smarter than average but
not really smart enough to grasp these
these broader Concepts and so you you
end up with
uh you know an example would be when uh
Alise stonic
says I will certify the El she's asked
will you commit to certifying the 2024
election she says yes if it's
constitutional and then NBC because
these people are scumbags and they're
evil report Alise toonic refuses to
commit to certifying the 2024 election
the midwit is the Democrat who then goes
whoa they understand enough of politics
they read into it but they're not smart
enough to grasp how they're being
manipulated they they don't have a
minute to think like well wait a minute
when should somebody certify election or
commit to certifying an election they
just like wo they didn't do the good
thing they're saying they won't do the
good thing salt in cookies did you know
that you put salt in your cookies when
you make them yes how many people have
you ever run into because I've run into
a lot where they get mad I've been in
numerous occasions where I've been
baking cookies and when I put when I
pulled the salt out they said don't put
salt in it what are you doing because
they thought you don't put salt in
desserts which you literally do wow
recipes but there are a lot of yeah
those must be terrible knowing those
cookies they didn't put any salt in them
yeah but a lot of they don't understand
the point of putting salt in food right
yeah and so they think cookies have
sugar not salt don't put salt in it
someone who is smart enough to
understand recipes can make cookies but
not smart enough to understand that yeah
sometimes things sound counterintuitive
it goes back to our educational system
because they have they don't they don't
teach I mean the whole the whole word
educate I think in Greek or Latin is to
discover within right and and that used
to be the process you would go and
actually try to become educated you
would learn you would have deductive
reasoning critical you know critical
reasoning skills so you would learn not
just reading writing and arithmetic but
you would learn how to debate somebody
right you'd have these conversations I
mean try pulling an average person in on
this show and have them just think and
debate I mean that just sadly that's not
happening and I think it's it's endemic
of the educational system that we have
today people just can't think for
themselves so so is part and partial
what I think you're going to say that
that's uh that's really a communist
ideology give somebody here you go no I
was just going to bring up the fact that
man on a street uh is is a thing that
everybody does for a reason because
there are plenty of plenty of hilarious
people out there thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. and become a member
over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time